Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There's a brand new daredevil Born Again First
Look Teaser
We finally have some actual footage
because they started filming the series again.
there's even footage of what looks like the Fantomex
character in More Mutants in the MCU.
There are a couple new episodes that they're filming.
They've already done a bunch of work for the series
I'll explain what's going on, who's coming back?
Because we see a whole bunch of Foggy Nelson and Karen
Page, and here we know The Punisher is coming back.
Jessica Jones is the next big defender
that is coming back.
They just announced Bullseye is coming back.
and based on everything, it seems like we're actually
getting a version of Daredevil Season four next year
when the show actually premieres.
So of course I'll do videos for everything.
Be sure to subscribe for your brand new to the channel.
this is really like the best possible case scenario.
Like we all thought that it was crazy
when Kevin Feige had to reboot the show.
Like, why would you do that?
What was so wrong about it before?
turns out they just wanted to make it as good
as it could possibly be.
if you been complaining about Marvel,
this is like a direct response to stuff like that.
now they're even using Daredevil born Again to connect
with Spider-Man four and set that movie up too.
So don't worry.
I'll talk about all those Spider-Man connections
during Daredevil Born Again During the video,
But the footage confirms
they're paying off a big teaser that they left off with
in Daredevil Season three, which is why we're saying
that they're effectively doing Daredevil Season four
is basically him
leaving his law firm of Murdock Nelson in Paige.
they finally did the thing.
And it sounds like this actually wasn't
in the original version of the show,
like they were going to kill off
Karen Page and Foggy Nelson.
That's why everybody was so upset
in the original version of the show.
Like, why would you do that?
he just wrote all of our names, didn't he?
How can you know the brand new showrunner.
The Kevin Feige hired is the showrunner
from the Punisher Netflix series.
they're the stunt coordinators
from the Daredevil Netflix series.
Like all the important crew members
who made the Netflix series
are Back to make Daredevil Born Again. But.
They apparently already shot episode one
so this footage isn't from episode
one is from some subsequent episode.
I believe that they already shot two additional extra
episodes on top of what they already did,
me, The episode count might be somewhere on par
with what the original Netflix series were,
which was usually about 13 episodes, minute
that they might have four extra episodes to fill.
Right now,
this scene is probably from one of those episodes,
some of the storyline that they're doing
for The Punisher during season one,
I think ties in with what they're doing
with the new villain Muse from the Daredevil comics.
I'll explain him in a second
because he's a relatively new character
in Marvel Comics, just in general, a lot of people
asking about the other defenders characters
Marvel just canonized
all the Netflix shows to the MCU or made it official.
I think a lot of people believe
that they were keen to the MCU.
Marvel just officially said something about that.
but the next big defender character that they haven't
talked about too much recently is Jessica Jones.
She was supposed to be featured
during Echo in Bigger during Daredevil
Born Again, but they changed a couple of things,
like they changed the Echo series.
There were a bunch of deleted scenes
with the Daredevil character
that were meant to set her up to
I believe in the original version.
Echo would have been talking to Daredevil
more regularly in present day,
and he would have been helping her
with her kingpin problem in the Black Knight cartel,
which she deals with during the series
in the final version that we saw,
they cut out one of the episodes completely
and you see Daredevil in the flashback to that period
during the five year time jump
when she was still a teenager
and faces him for the first time.
all the events of the Echo
series are meant to take place in 2025.
The events of Daredevil Born Again
are like a little bit of a time jump.
Later, in 2026 inside the MCU.
so this is meant to take place
after the events of Spider-Man No way Home confirming
another big Spider-Man connection here
with Karen Page and Foggy Nelson.
if they're using the Murdock Nelson and page law firm
during these episodes, it means the law
firm would have existed had been active
during the events of Spider-Man No Way Home, meaning
that he would have been working with them, working
at this law firm when he was helping Spider-Man.
During the events of that movie So it depends.
You're Foggy Nelson and Karen Page
running around in their office in the background,
talking about the Spider-Man problem, quote unquote,
like how are we going to help this Spider-Man kid out
For those of you wondering about
the effects of the spell at the end of that movie,
the whole idea is that it would erase
all the knowledge that Peter Parker was Spider-Man
from Daredevil's mind, everyone else's mind.
But because of Daredevil's senses,
he would probably instantly learn that Peter Parker
was Spider-Man if they ran into each other again,
which it sounds like they will.
By the events of Spider-Man four.
this brand new character that everybody thinks is
Phantom X does look kind of like Phantom X is Comics
is probably going to be the MCU version
of the White Tiger character.
lot of people have questions about this.
It's not Bucky
because Bucky is the white wolf, not white tiger.
White Tiger is a completely different character.
the character did appear in the Heroes for hire
comics, Daredevil, Spider-Man comics.
The original version
gained superhuman powers using a talisman.
So it sounds like they're going with a version of that
in the MCU show,
some of the other footage here features
the brand new villain moves like you see this
kingpin mural that he creates
that's based on his comic book storyline
with a gruesome, quote
unquote murals that he creates with his victims.
it sounds like there's going to be an escalation
even with the villain, like he creates
regular murals,
then starts doing it with bodies in the comics.
Muse is meant to be kind of like a street level.
Gorr, the God butcher,
trying to call out a lot of hypocrisy.
This happening in New York City,
Hell's Kitchen, for instance,
because we're talking about daredevil characters here
It is inspired to do a lot of this in a horrific
kind of way because of what Daredevil is doing.
he's trying to create works of art to show people
what reality is really like, what it can be like.
But he's killing a bunch of people to do it
for instance, in one case,
he takes down a judge, a cop and a politician
to create one of his art pieces, quote unquote.
And it's meant to be his commentary
on the failure of the legal system in Hell's Kitchen.
would have been like Gorr, the God butcher
going around killing a bunch of the gods
like zoos, all these other people,
and turning them into a work of art
and making it a commentary
on the failure of the gods in the MCU.
I know there are all kinds of complaints
about the way they did Gorr during that movie.
Like he didn't butcher a whole lot of gods
during that the comic book storyline way, way better.
If you're a big fan of Gorr
bemuse is basically Gorr on street level.
and it sounds like based on this mural here
with the black and the white, he's
actually going to be going after Kingpin
in, I think, because they did this in the comics, too.
So they're basically just doing
the comics is the kingpin uses all of what Mewes
does like all of his victims all of his crime scenes
to push his anti vigilante agenda and go
after Daredevil, Spider-Man, Punisher, all the street
level heroes, branding them as dangerous vigilantes.
sort of like what he did during Daredevil Season
three by putting Bullseye in the Daredevil costume,
then having Bullseye do all these crazy things
and get in trouble with the police
making it seem like it was Daredevil
doing all these terrible things, killing people.
as the new they're using music storyline
from the comics to parallel kingpin
storyline in Daredevil seasons with his love of art.
Like the whole idea that Vanessa was an art dealer
sold him all these paintings.
Amuse is creating all these fine art pieces,
but just doing a lot of crazy stuff
to do it, like killing a bunch of people, to do it.
one of the few changes
I think they're going to make with that storyline,
though, is that he was actually using a lot of Inhumans
in the comics to do it, and they haven't canonized
Inhumans in the main 616 MCU universe yet.
They did canonize them with black bolt in Doctor
Strange multiverse of madness.
But that was the 838 universe.
So yes, Inhumans are canon.
Like Ms..
Marvel in the comics wasn't inhuman, but they changed
her to an X-Men mutant character inside the MCU.
so. Maybe.
Maybe they'll be some mutant references
during Daredevil Born Again.
but I don't think we're going to see a lot of X-Men
related stuff inside the main MCU universe
until that brand new X-Men movie Deadpool
three does have a lot of X-Men related stuff in it,
but it's meant to be more of a multiverse movie
with other universes.
Right now, in the MCU, like,
the biggest mutant really is stuff that we've had.
They've canonized is basically namor in Ms.. Marvel.
but here's where this crosses over
with the Punisher's storyline.
And this is a big comic book
thing in the Daredevil comics featuring use
a lot of his crazy
art pieces feature references to street level heroes.
Punisher, for instance, is a big one in the comics.
So you to imagine Muse creating this art piece,
it being really gruesome crime scene.
It references the Punisher
like he looks up to the Punisher and what he's doing.
Then Kingpin uses that as an example of why
they need to get rid of all the vigilantes.
Like, see, this is all because of the Punisher.
He's to blame for all this.
before they completely rebooted. Daredevil born again.
There was a slightly different Punisher storyline.
I don't know if that survived in the new version,
maybe a small version of that where Punisher
was basically killing corrupt cops that were also
using his symbol to do a bunch of really shady stuff.
I don't know how many episodes Foggy Nelson is in.
Karen
Page is supposed to be in at least three episodes.
I think Jessica Jones was also supposed to be
in a couple of episodes, too.
But like I said, her storyline changed a little bit.
So that might be a little bit different
in the final version that we all see right now,
the only reason why Luke Cage isn't
directly coming back like they canonized all the shows
like Luke Cage stuff is canon to the MCU.
but the actor Mike Colter is just busy doing other
series, so he's unavailable to actually film episodes.
So it's not like they're going to recast
Luke Cage or anything like that.
They'll just wait for him to be ready
to be able to come back in
and have a storyline that justifies him coming back.
it's one of those situations where, like Kevin Feige
brings Daredevil back and Spider-Man No Way Home,
Kingpin back in Hawkeye in Before that he never said
that they were not canon officially to the MCU.
He just never featured them in the MCU.
that's why I usually hear Kevin Feige
being really quiet about stuff like that.
Like when people ask him about X-Men inside the MCU
or Inhumans eventually showing up in the MCU,
usually you just don't hear him talk about it
because they might already have a plan for that.
But that plan could change lot of people
now asking about the agents of SHIELD characters
because they went through so much trouble
to canonize all the Marvel Netflix shows to the MCU.
What about Agents of Shield?
There were a couple of trailers
when they were all putting this stuff on Disney Plus,
where they featured the agents of Shield characters.
there was a little bit of drama
behind the scenes between Kevin Feige, the Marvel
TV people, and Joss Whedon
when they were creating that show.
Apparently Kevin Feige really, really hated
that they brought Coulson back for Agents of Shield.
end, even though it sounds like he likes
all the agents of SHIELD people
that actually did the show, like the actors themselves,
even the writers that worked on the show.
it sounds like he wasn't super happy
that the show itself just existed
now it sounds like it's more of a continuity issue
where they're not quite sure how they want to introduce
Inhumans to the main MCU universe
because they're doing so much X-Men stuff.
First, the producers kind of got into this
when they were explaining why it took so long
for them to officially recognized
the Netflix shows as can into the MCU.
And there was a lot of behind the scenes
politicking in them just figuring out how to fit them
into the continuity to be fair, though, it's way easier
for them to do that with the Marvel Netflix series
because they don't have a lot of crazy Inhumans stuff
that happened during the Netflix series
Ease of Shield is a little bit different.
so yes, I do
think we'll eventually see agents of SHIELD characters
show up in MCU projects in the future.
Like Chloe. Ben has character.
Ming-Na, Wen, Coulson is a little bit harder,
a little less likely in present day.
But he has come back and flashbacks already.
but if there were any question, everybody
that is coming back during Daredevil
born again is mostly just Marvel Netflix people.
But if they're canonizing all this stuff,
let me know which other characters you want to see.
Come back next.
I've already done videos about Iron Fist too
because there is a version of Iron Fist
that we're going to see
during one of the Marvel TV series later this year,
but it's a slightly different version.
Click here to learn about that and click here to learn
how Daredevil
Born Again
is meant to set up the events of Spider-Man 4
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!